wie viel Miete zahlst du in Berl willst
du wissen wie tiktok mir geholfen hat
willkommen zu vlogmas Tag 15 heute habe
ich ein tattootermin und dafür fahren
wir noch ne Köln zu meiner
lieblingstätowiererin aber Plot ich
krieg ein featto gemeinsam mit meiner
Freundin
anni so jetzt sind wir
hier vor ein paar Wochen haben wir
Steffi unsere Idee gegeben und nun
stellt sie uns erstmal ihre Entwürfe vor
sowas hier hatte ich noch mir überlegt
vielleicht so ganz clean auch fand ich
auch irgendwie süß dass das so nur so
ein Dreieck ist mhm ich mag auch diesen
Anker der so ein bisschen reinversteckt
ist
so ich habe noch ein dritten okay oh
Gott der hat tolle Augen dert auch ganz
sü also da bin ich so ein bisschen
weggegangen von diesen frontalen und
dachte vielleicht so ein bisschen
niedlicher von der Seite oder irgendwie
so nebeninander ne also hier ist ja der
den ich die erst geschickt hatte weil er
würde natürlich gut in diese Lücke
passen ja also weil die nicht so groß
die gibt ja nicht so viel her ja also
Partner Cream ist schon lustig ja also
Leute wir haben uns jetzt entschieden
das wird jetzt dieser waschbeer dafür
haben wir uns vorher schon entschieden
sagen ja Partner in cream aber aber als
ich den gesehen habe dachte ich auch
sofort so das ist er ja
siehter du machst so ein bisschen
zentraler ne ich werde ihn auch hier so
oh dann können wir aber voll schlecht
warte mal wenn wir dann so stehen und
dann die Leute sagen h warum waschbe
dann cream oh wartete so und dann machen
wir zum Schluss so ein Move warte so und
dann
ja aber warte wenn wir dann wenn wir
dann so zusammen dann können wir einfach
unsere Arme drehen und dann machen wir
oh dann machen wir so
freundschaftsfotos an der Elbe an der
Elbe machen wir ein Fotoshooting so
haben wir früher wirklich gemacht und in
den Obstgärten haben wir früher auch
Fotoshootings gemacht wir sind schon
seit 20 Jahren befreundet unsere
Freundschaft hat in der fünften Klasse
damals angefangen wir sind jetzt seit 20
Jahren befreundet also nächstes Jahr ist
unser 20-jähriges und da ist es mal Zeit
für ein freundschaftsatto ist doch jetzt
mal ganz ehrlich also ja und warum
waschbe erzählen wir euch vielleicht
später aber jetzt haben wir uns erstmal
entschieden Steffi macht jetzt noch die
letzten Feinheiten und dann geht's auch
schon
los jetzt machen wir erstmal
scheresteinpier wer anfangen
muss Schere steinier Schere Stein
Papier Gewinnerin ich darf zuerst gut
weil wenn man schon so lange so sieht
wieer eine so am Leiden ist
halt ja undem wenn es nicht so gut
aussieht kann ich sagen hier ist die
vorbei ich darf anfangen ich habe schin
Papier gewonnen na
herrlich soll ich mein Pulli ausziehen
besser ne kannst einfach hochchieben
also ihr nicht wisst was Sie Steffi da
gerade tut sie bereitet die Stelle vor
und cremt mich ein manche kommen ja nur
für manche
kommen das schmiger ich s
ja das ist es das ist es für mich wir
reden gerade darüber wie schmerzfrei
oder schmerzhaft die Stelle ist aber es
kommt auch immer darauf an welchem Tag
man sich in seinem Zyklus befindet wie
sehr das weh tut mal gucken manchmal ist
es aber eigentlich ein
überraschungsbonbon wie doll es weh tut
oh das ist aber echt eine gemütliche
Position gerade aber letztes Mal war ich
auch glaube ich BZ entspannt mal gucken
aber die ersten 5 Minuten sind eh immer
die schlimmsten ich habe immer das
Gefühl bei den ersten 5 Minuten denk man
so warum tue ich mir das denn jetzt
schon wieder an also man vergisst immer
von dem Tattoo davor wie es weh getan
hat und dann erinnert man sich
so hast du ein mit
Akku du hast nicht mal ein Kabel mehr
[Musik]
dran
ja ich warte jetzt hier bis ich dran bin
und gucke mir ein Buch an das macht man
so bei Tätowierern falls ihr noch nie
beim Tätowierer bei der Tätowiererin
wart in dem Laden wenn man wartet guckt
man sich einfach Bücher an das ist jetzt
ein gedrucktes Buch eigentlich guckst du
dir so kleine Fotoalben an mit entweder
schon fotografierten Tattoos oder mit
kleinen wedos wenn du also gar keine
Idee hast und unkreativ bist dann kannst
du dir die Kreativität deines
Tätowierers zu Nutzen machen das war ein
schöner Monolog gerade WoW oder danke ja
zeig mal an was Du so für Tattoos hast
money
Ryan der raucht nicht das ist eine
schokozigarette und das ist Frankie der
hat eine bewegliches Horn und dann habe
ich noch oh warte Hose aus ja ich habe
eine Hose drunter keine Angst mamaabär
viele Details 9 Stunden Arbeit liebe ich
sehr ist ein richtig tolles artpiece
würde ich mal sagen das ist mein zweites
Tattoo ja ja da war ich 18 Leute das
hier ist eine Pizza Margarita Margarite
haha lustig habe ich mir aus Italien
mitgenommen aus Rom das hier ist auch
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen schwierig
für manche Leute das ist eine allraune
ist aber auch ein bisschen ausgetrocknet
das ist so die trockneste Stelle meines
Körpers und das hier habe ich mal
gewonnen das ist von Bernt muss und bei
Bernt muss würde ich mich nie tätowieren
lassen weil der ist sehr sehr teuer na
ja aber trotzdem jetzt habe ich auf
jeden Fall ein kleines Art artpiece von
ihm das habe ich bei
whiskyem Whisky Tasting gewonnen mein
allererstes Tattoo mein wartet das hier
die schweibe am Halz ganz klassisch ein
ganz klassisches mädchenattoo was man
sich auch mit gerade 18 geworden stechen
lässt und Vanessa hat sich den Anker auf
dem Rücken machen lassen der Anker auf
dem Rücken und die schweibe am Hals ja
das ist also eins meiner
lieblingstattoos weil es immer noch nach
12 Jahren wunderschön aussieht
Schmerzlevel ist okay ich habe das
Gefühl langsam sagt mein Arm so aua und
machst du gerade noch die Outlines oder
füllst du schon aus sowohl als
auch Linien sind eigentlich schon fast
alle da jetzt mache ich schon so ein
paar Schatten Steffi malt dir gerade ihr
Malbuch aus ganz Berlin ist dein Malbuch
ja überall sind ihre Bilder macht dir
dein Beruf Spaß Steffi klar ich bin
hergekommen und wir hatten halt Partner
in crime irgendwie cool gefunden und ich
hatte ihr gesagt waschbeer und dann
vielleicht auch ein Eis oder so ich
wusste aber gar nicht was da jetzt so
kommt und dann hat sie halt einfach
Partner in cream gemacht und Annie und
ich sind aber wir lieben auch Wortwitze
wir sind da dafür sind wir sehr
empfindlich so ein Melan Ding weißt
[Musik]
du aber wir sind in dem finalen wir sind
im finalen auf dem finalen wir sind wir
sind auf dem Weg zum Finale
[Musik]
Finale ich bin F fertig bin
ich die
waschb und dann war anni an der Reihe ne
wir sind wie Adam und Eva und Eva wird
jetzt hier gerade aus meinem Fleisch
geformt aus meinem Vorbild wirda will
ich
[Gelächter]
sagen aus Adams ha hafter
geschnitten jetzt fragt ihr euch
bestimmt warum lassen wir uns waschb
Tätowieren als wir in der Schule waren
sind wir in der Pause immer im
Klassenraum geblieben und haben von
unseren Freunden von den Brötchen und
von den Süßigkeiten genascht die sie mit
zur Schule genommen haben und da haben
wir uns immer früher waschbeeren genannt
und wurden auch von unseren
Klassenkameraden waschbeen genannt und
das Eis hat der waschb in der Hand weil
wir uns jeden Freitag in der eisdele
zwei Kugeln Eis für 14 geholt haben wie
geht's Ihnen Frau Böcker den Umständen
entsprechend ja
okay sie sind jetzt fertig ja der Arm er
brennt BR dir auch so
bisschen und wie lief es also sie haben
gesehen in der ersten halbe Halbzeit
waren sie ja ganz stabil unterwegs ja
und die letzten 5 Minuten letzten
ze aber jetzt fühlt sich an als wenn man
sich hätte ja aber du hast dich nicht
viel beschwert muss ich sagen also ich
habe ein bisschen mehr gem ich glaube
ich habe mich unbeobachtet gefühlt bis
ich gecheckt habe Scheiße die ist ich
habe so meine arschwacken so
zusamek aber dann war auch hier der
coole Typ da dann wollte man natürlich
nicht rumschreien und sagen es tut de
weh ja wir zeigen jetzt noch mal unsere
Tattoos
warte Entschuldigung wir hallo
entschuldigung ich wohne hier
auch aber mein auch de auch ne ja ja
ja können auch das Design machen so
waschbeerenmanagement aufmachen oder
sotim Partner Partner in Cream ist auch
ein geiler Name Agentur Management
Partner in cream na ja darus entstehen
noch weitere Business Ideen Leute wir
nimmt uns das weg es war übrigens auch
Steffis Spruch deswegen müssen wir sie
erstmal fragen ob wir den benutzen
dürfen für irgendein
Management also wenn ihr bei Partner
undam unterschreiben wollt seid ihr
Junge Creator dann kommt zu uns
schaut uns doch an wie seriös wir
sind wir leben für Firma partner and
cream Partner in cream versammelt euch
das ist dann oh das ist wie das Harry
Potter mal das fängt dann an zu jucken
wenn einer an den anderen denkt oh
vielen Dank Steffi für diese tolle
Arbeit wir freuen uns sehr sehr gerne
also falls ihr mal in Neuköln seid dann
geht doch mal zu Rose aufland
und geh zu Steffi ne bitte sie kann das
gut